(upbeat music)
- Welcome to the Think Marketing Show,
the number one podcast for growing
and scaling your business
with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell,
and we're from Think Media.
And if this is your first
time listening, welcome.
- This show is dedicated
to helping you learn
how to get your content noticed
and the latest money making strategies
working right now online.
So whether you wanna
grow your YouTube channel
or maximize online video
across social media,
this is for you.
So today, we have something
really special for you.
We hosted our sold out
video marketing conference,
Grow With Video Live,
where we dove into the latest strategies
for video marketing and online business.
Shout out to everyone
from the Think community
who came to that.
And this year, it was just electric.
We brought together the Think
Media team, we had guests,
and it was just amazing
to see just the power
that's happening right
now in online video.
And today, we're bringing
you Sean Cannell's
keynote from that event.
Now, what I loved about
this keynote specifically,
was that Sean really shared his journey,
he talked about how he
was a college dropout,
and now he's running a
multimillion-dollar media company.
Sean's gonna share with you
some of the latest video stats
that you need to know right now,
and how it's gonna affect
your business this year.
Also, how to stay motivated
so you can keep creating
content all year long.
And why now is the best time to be using
online video for your business.
So let's jump over to the keynote now.
- We're gonna kick it
off right now, all right,
with just our first session all about
kinda get on the same page
of what's the future of
online video right now,
and why should we go all in,
and what's that all about?
But as we mentioned, our mission
here is to help you build
your influence with social media.
And in this session, we're
gonna be talking about
some must know stats
and online video trends.
10 reasons to go all in
with online video right now,
as well as how to stay more motivated
to create social media
content and to push through
when we, sometimes things get tough.
But if we're just meeting my name's Sean,
and my background is I
live now here in Las Vegas
with my wife Sonja, our two Chihuahuas.
But we actually started and grew up
in Washington State, right?
Maybe you've heard of Seattle before.
Washington's pretty, we had
Starbucks starting there,
of course, Microsoft, Nirvana, Macklemore,
come on all coming out of the Northwest.
And so, Amazon of course,
it's like a tech culture.
That's what's amazing about
Washington is it's tech,
it's future thinking, Seattle.
But that's actually not where I grew up.
I actually did not grow up
anywhere near really Seattle.
I grew up in the country.
It was Arlington, Washington.
I got my parents in the front row here.
We grew up.
(audience cheering)
We grew up like, we grew up on six acres,
we had like quads and like
goats and some horses.
Yeah, kinda crazy stuff.
Here's me, I mean, I was in a tree.
This was before social media.
I know parents are like, "I
wish my kids would go outside."
We did, 'cause we didn't
have anything else.
We didn't have power.
Just kidding, we had power.
But what I love about this is I grew up
and didn't have any
connections in Hollywood
and no one really in our
family was into video
or that kinda stuff, but
it just shows you the power
that when you just punch fear in the face,
and you press record, and you
can just start in a bedroom,
that amazing things can happen.
And for me, I actually got
started in my local church.
2003 I started shooting video,
and you can see it's just
a ragtag group there.
I actually, the person
that got me into video,
his name's Jeff Moore's,
he's my youth pastor.
He's sitting right over here.
Jeff stand up just so people could.
We probably wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for Jeff Moore's.
And, man, we were balling
on a budget though,
you can see those Home Depot
lights and the screens there.
Right, that was some,
that was green screen
from Joan Fabrics, right?
Some of you might relate, you're like,
"I don't got much money, right?
"I got my phone and some duct tape,"
and that's all you need.
And then for years, I was
waiting tables at Red Robin
and then just doing videos for my church
and just kinda learning video.
And my first videos were my worst videos
just like yours, right?
But you were kinda building those muscles,
getting through it.
Then in 2009 I started a
video production business
and got a little bit deeper into video.
And it was in Think Media,
it was in 2010 that Think
Media actually started
and I uploaded my first
video on that channel.
And we saw a little bit of
it, but let's check it out
just to kinda take it back for a moment.
All right, so this is I guess
the first Sean Thinks vlog,
and I'm gonna try to
vlog every single day,
mainly so I can remember
what I'm even doing
and what's going on 'cause I
just feel like I have a lot
that I'm thinking about and I
figured hey, why not share it,
and if you find something
interesting, that's awesome.
Now this is definitely as real as it gets,
so I'm not gonna try to be
energetic or entertaining,
though maybe sometimes I will.
Anyways...
(audience laughing)
Yeah, yeah, man.
(audience cheering)
You know that just, that really reminds me
of this quote by Zig
Ziglar, and it's this,
"You don't have to be great to start,
"but you have to start to be great."
You gotta just start.
You gotta just press record,
and that's what I did,
and now we've seen the
power of online video
over these last years, of
course, not just in the world,
but in our business.
I mean, going from just
shooting videos in a bedroom
to now building a multiple
seven figure company,
it's been crazy to see
the power of social media
and online video.
And so as we start today, let's
talk about why online video.
And I'm kinda preaching to the choir.
I mean, you already have
come here to Grow With Video.
But there's some very
interesting stats we need to know
in regards to where video is going
and even where it is right now.
Cisco says that by 2022
online video will make up
more than 82% of consumer
internet traffic,
that's 15 times higher
than it was in 2017.
This is the rapid
acceleration of video period.
And consumers by the way,
those are the people
you're trying to reach.
Whether that's with
your products, services,
as an influencer, video is the format,
it's what's growing
more than anything else.
78% of people watch
online videos every week,
and 55% of people view
online videos every day.
Who's in that 55%?
That's me, man.
Every single day, like I'm probably seeing
some kinda online video.
Six out of 10 people would rather
watch online videos than television.
And as culture shifts, it's
funny my wife Sonja and I
oftentimes we'll sit
down after a day's work,
we turn on our Smart TV, and
we don't go anywhere else
we go to YouTube first.
I turn on Phil DeFranco, I
get filled in on my news.
I turn on a couple other, we
go through our subscriptions.
It's interesting how culture is shifting.
In fact, you could see it here
that TV consumption is going down
while online video has
surpassed that and is going up
in terms of here in the U.S.
time spent consuming content.
Now, on social media, where
you're going to be reaching
your target audience, the
people you wanna reach,
social media posts with
video have 48% more views
than posts without video.
And social video generates
1200% more shares
than text and image content combined.
So uploading video, not just YouTube,
but uploading video on Twitter,
on Instagram, on LinkedIn,
on these different
platforms is very powerful
for getting more reach.
Now, 65% of people use YouTube
to help them solve a problem.
In this room, you could write this down,
and I hope you're taking notes
throughout this conference
even just, even if you
throw them away after,
it helps us kind of retain the
information we're learning.
But when I think about this,
here's what question all
of us need to answer,
what problem do you solve?
You gotta know that.
And when you know that, people
are going to the internet,
they go to Google, they go to YouTube
to help solve a problem.
And maybe that's how to
get more views on YouTube
or how to save money on your taxes
or how to have a stronger relationship
or how to go deeper in
your faith, whatever it is,
and people are looking
for answers on YouTube,
you need to be showing
up with those answers.
Now, a website is 53
times more likely to reach
the front page of Google
if it includes video.
So as business owners
having video integrated
on our website, embedded
in different posts,
very critical to get more
reach on our websites.
And then nearly 50% of
internet users look for videos
related to a product or service
before visiting a store.
So with what we're seeing
now is online video
being kind of a synergy of
what's happening offline.
And so you want to have any
kind of product you have,
any kind of service you have,
you want video describing that
educating about that,
because people wanna research you first,
kinda stock you a little bit online,
and then maybe do business with you later.
Now, this is where it gets crazy.
3.48 billion people, roughly
45% of the world's population,
use social media.
No, no, half the world is
active on social media.
And you don't need to be told in this room
that this is where the future is going.
But for some business owners,
and here's the opportunity,
last night at our kinda
networking party, I was talking to
a couple different people
about their industries.
I was talking to people especially,
whether it's the residential
service industry,
or maybe some kind of
traditional business industries,
where they're like, "Our people
aren't quite online yet."
Here's the thing, we're
seeing them all come online.
And one out of two people on planet earth
are on social media apps.
You need to be on social
media apps, right?
Now, here's the breakdown
of the monthly active users
on the key platforms.
By the way, these are the
platforms that pretty much
we think are relevant when
it comes to video right now.
Active on Twitter, you
have 326 million people
active on Twitter.
LinkedIn, probably one of
the most important platforms
for us as professionals
to be active on right now,
uploading video content,
as well as text pictures.
260 million monthly active
users on that platform.
It's the wealthiest social
network out of all of them,
regardless of users because
it's where business is done.
It's where professionals
are, it's where brands are.
People on LinkedIn have money.
So if you are looking to do
business, build your income,
you wanna be active on LinkedIn.
TikTok is hot right now.
Now, raise your hand if
you know what TikTok is
and you have the app, raise it high,
I'm just gonna survey the room.
Not too bad, not too bad.
So maybe 20% of the room.
So TikTok right now some are saying
is maybe the biggest
threat to like an Instagram
which is one of the hottest
platforms right now.
Something to kind of put on your radar,
definitely a younger demographic,
but that's always where it starts,
and then things usually age up,
so something to be paying attention to.
Of course, Instagram, Facebook,
YouTube, massive saturation.
Here's the bottom line.
When you get your marketing
right, your messaging right,
you get your business setup
right, your communication right,
your customers are here.
There is no shortage of customers for you.
There's just you needing to reach them
and connect with them.
There's no shortage of money
in the economy for your business.
There's no reason you
should not be prospering.
I get it, you gotta, it's
tough and there's a struggle
and different things, but there are,
this is an insane amount of people.
It's about getting in front of them on,
by the way, every single
one of these platforms
is free to use, free to use.
- In celebration of the launch
of this brand new podcast,
we're giving away two tickets
to our annual conference,
Grow With Video Live, a $1500 value.
- All you have to do to enter
is make sure you subscribe,
leave us a review on Apple Podcasts,
and then take a screenshot of your review
and go to thinkmarketingshow.com
for the rest of the details.
Now we're gonna go and talk
just about phones a little bit,
we're gonna talk about smartphones.
Nearly 3/4 of the world will use
just their smartphones to
access the internet by 2025.
So what we need to be aware
of as we think of kind of
the broad reach of this
is also that right now,
the screen that you're
gonna be reaching the people
that you need to reach is right here.
That this is the window to the world.
And that not only is that true now,
but it's increasingly true.
By 2025 three quarters of the
earth will have this device
so therefore you can reach
them on these platforms.
51% of time spent online
is spent on mobile devices,
and so through all of the
people on the internet,
over half and that number is growing,
the majority are on mobile.
Now, the average U.S.
adult will spend two hours,
this is where it gets kinda awkward,
and 55 minutes on their
smartphone per day.
Anybody, is that you?
That's me.
- Yeah.
- They say some people,
they say that's the average.
They say crazy people
it's over five hours,
it's over five hours, it's very.
We have people like pointing people.
Yeah.
(laughs)
That's so funny.
And so the average adult,
yeah, two hours on their phone.
Now, the majority of that time
is being spent on social media.
So out of that almost three hours,
two hours and 23 minutes
per day is on social media.
What is the point I'm trying to make?
This is the device that we're
gonna be reaching people
and the main thing that people
are using on this device
is social platforms.
Those social platforms are free
and you creating relevant content
that's valuable to get in
front of your target audience
is massively powerful.
This graph right here also shows
us the increase since 2012.
And so what's the trend of online video?
This isn't slowing down, this is going up.
We see this continuing to grow
and so there's massive opportunity for us.
Now, here's how many times
we touch our phones per day.
The typical cell phone user
touches his or her phone
2,617 times per day.
So this is including touching
it, typing on it, right,
like doing some stuff, maybe
play a game or something.
Or if you're like me, if
you're just compulsive,
and every once in a while you look around
and you just touch it.
Do you ever do that?
I'm on meetings, I'm listening to Heather
and Melissa talk for a
second and then I'm like,
okay, and I start zoning
out and I just start like,
and I'm like, oh I should be
listening and it's like, right?
And that's just the average user,
extreme cell phone users, the top 10%,
they touch their phones 5,400 times a day.
Look at the person next to you
and say you've got a problem,
you've really got a problem, yeah.
(audience speaking faintly)
Yeah.
Now, now here's the deal,
you came to Grow With Video,
I'm not here to preach about
whether this is good or bad,
I will leave that up to the psychologists.
I'm not here to discuss
any of those things.
But for us as business owners,
we just need to understand
that this is true.
And that whether it's
healthy or not, regardless,
there's a lot of opportunity there
'cause people are glued to these things,
scarily, so isn't it?
I mean, I've been driving
lately I'm seeing this,
just yesterday I got my haircut,
I was going through this parking
lot, I saw this woman, man
she was just whipping
through the parking lot just,
she wasn't even.
And I was I was like, dear God.
If I was in front, I would
have died if I was in front.
I watched the whole thing happen,
luckily she was unobstructed,
but again, I'm not here
to discuss those things,
I'll leave that up to the psychologists.
This is massive
opportunity for you and me.
This is where attention is.
This is where you need to be.
Now, finally,
digital audio, curve ball,
digital audio accounts
for the biggest share
of time spent on these mobile devices.
"Well, Sean, this is a video conference."
Yes, but what the stats
show us is actually that
what people are listening
to the most is audio.
And then it says social media
is next, and video is third.
So right now on our phones,
people are spending
the most time on audio.
Then they're spending time on social media
and then they're consuming video.
What we're gonna be talking a
lot about at this conference
is video podcasting.
It is our belief that
many of us in this room,
I believe all of us should
be focusing on digital audio
considering to start a podcast.
Who already has a podcast?
Wave at me.
Awesome, so a few people in the room.
Now when you video podcast,
what's amazing is you get all of these,
because if you record the
audio as well with video,
you could hit YouTube, you
can also hit that podcast,
you can go on Spotify now for free, right?
You can upload clips in social
media put content on YouTube.
So by doing a video podcast
that is the most
strategic way to dominate,
and we're gonna be going a lot deeper
in that throughout the day.
So what's the point?
Man, it's time to go all in.
It's time to go all in.
You came to Vegas to sit
here at Grow With Video,
not to go all in at the blackjack tables,
but to go all in in video.
And what I mean by that is like, again,
this is where people's attention is.
The statistics are in, the results are in
this is modern marketing.
And this is also where
it's most underpriced.
Can you still do billboards,
and do people see 'em?
Sure; can you still do television ads?
Absolutely; can you still do radio?
Absolutely.
But these are free platforms.
We also highly encourage
and we'll be discussing
paid traffic on these platforms.
But this is where it's happening.
And when I say go all
in, what I mean by that
is that we gotta really lean in.
I mean, you already bought
a ticket to this conference,
and you're here, but when I
say it's not just about money,
this is about our time,
it's about our energy,
it's about our strategy, it's
about really putting our heart
our strength, our emotions into this,
because the opportunity is that big.
And I've learned that
half hearted efforts,
never get great results.
That someone that is your competitor
and someone in your industry,
they are going all in.
And so they understand this opportunity,
and they're jacked up, they're fired up,
and they're leaning into this,
you're here to make that decision today.
If there's one thing I
want you to take away
from this session, maybe
even this conference,
is that you would say,
man, I'm gonna commit to this thing,
I see it, the writing's on the wall,
it is time to go all in.
Look at your neighbor and say
go all in, and tell 'em that.
(audience speaking faintly)
Look at the person on the other side
and say you really need
to go all in, you really,
you especially I mean, yeah.
But here's the problem, here's
the problem, like I said,
you probably are hearing like,
"Yeah, I mean, that's why I'm here.
"I bought a ticket, man.
"I flew from New York,
bro, I mean, I'm all in."
The problem, I think is
this stat right here.
It's not that we don't know
that we need to go all in
but 83% of marketers would
increase their reliance on video,
and strategy, if there were
no obstacles like time,
resource and budgets.
And so that's what we're
talking about today.
We're gonna talk about, and
Heather's gonna be sharing
a little bit about productivity
and how do we actually
optimize some of these things
so we can implement them in our business.
If we had more resources,
if we had more budget.
But you know what that looks like to me,
most marketers are making excuses.
Most marketers are being little sissies.
For real man.
Like I would do a lot of things,
like, "Man I would be
in a lot better shape
"if I had more time,
resources and motivation,"
you know what I mean?
It's everything.
I love this quote from Thomas Edison,
"Opportunity is missed by most people
"because it's dressed in
overalls and it looks like work."
You gotta go all in, and we
gotta overcome these obstacles,
and that's what we're gonna do today.
And one of the things that we've learned
as it pertains to going
all in is it's not enough
to really just have kind of
like mental comprehension,
but actually needs to be something
that we truly buy into at a heart level.
We like to say that reasons
come before results.
Reasons come before results.
When you've got strong enough reasons
that gets you up and
motivated to do the extra work
that maybe after a hard
day's work in your business,
you're like, "Sean, I mean, I'm maxed out.
"I got client calls, I got stuff to do.
"I got delivery of services,
I got all this stuff."
That when you get home after
a hard day's work, you go,
but I get this online video,
this video podcasting thing's real,
so I'm gonna hustle an extra
hour, two hours, three hours,
four hours to get in that extra time.
But you have to have strong
enough reasons to do that.
That reminds me of really
my drive and my motivation,
and it kinda goes back
to when we were in the
hardest season of our life.
You may have heard our story before,
but my wife Sonja and I, we
actually got married in 2000.
When we were 21, we got married in 2005.
We just celebrated our 14th
anniversary, September 9th.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Thank you.
And so we got married
young, we got married at 21.
And it was.
(audience sighs in awe)
Yeah.
And so we're this young couple,
we've got big dreams, young, vibrant,
just ready to take on the world.
But in just a...
And at the time we were hustling.
I mentioned I started my business in 2009.
So I was doing my business
Clear Vision Media.
My wife Sonja had multiple jobs.
She's working at Starbucks,
she's waiting tables.
She was nanning for some friends of ours.
I was waiting tables at Red Robin.
That's not actually how my hair looked,
that was Halloween, I was
Wayne from Wayne's World
at that time.
Would have been awesome, though.
I mean, I think maybe I should do that.
That's Grow With Video next
year, if I start now, ha-ha.
And we were kinda dabbling on YouTube,
and we were going all these things,
but then we hit the
hardest season of our life.
And after we got married,
just two years later,
my wife got very sick.
She actually went on a
trip to the Philippines,
and came back, we didn't
know what's going on,
and she's throwing up
five, 10, 15 times a day
for a few years.
Doctor after doctor after doctor
had no idea what was going on.
And over two years, she began to lose
all this kinda weight and
eventually got to a place
where she was hospitalized
and almost died.
And I found myself in the
hospital room with her
for six days, just kinda by her bedside,
trying to figure out man,
what are we gonna do?
What are we gonna do next?
And if that wasn't enough,
some of you can probably
relate to going through
The Big Short, the crash
of the economy 2008, 2009.
And we were going through that time too.
We actually had a rental
property, we had a house.
And so now we're dealing
with chronic illness,
we're dealing with kinda job loss,
and now we're losing our homes.
And you can imagine the weight
and the pressure of that.
And if that wasn't enough,
I mentioned I started in church, right?
And I was working at that church.
Well, at that church, some
people stole some money
and things started falling apart.
There was this massive
momentum and movement,
but it just began to just fall to pieces.
And now you also had people you trusted
and people you looked
up to that let you down.
And so we really felt like,
man, what is happening?
Things were literally
falling apart all around us.
We're losing money,
we're losing our homes.
I have no idea what's gonna
happen with my wife's health,
what our future holds.
And maybe you can relate to
a season like this, right?
Maybe right now you're
in a season like this
or you can look back
to a season like this,
dealing with uncertainty,
overwhelm, right?
You're scared, you're afraid.
And it was during this season
that I really realized man, life is short.
You get punched in the
face with this kinda stuff
at a super young age and it
kinda wakes you up to like,
whoa, life is short.
And I begin to ask questions like,
man, are we really maxing out
and living at like at the highest level?
Made me think like, man, am I really
spending quality time with my family?
Have I really spent
quality time with my wife?
Do I have that freedom
to spend time with her?
Because in a moment,
maybe she could be gone?
Maybe I could be gone in a moment.
And you start to think about these things.
And then who was I really
as a man and as a leader?
I working in ministry,
I was waiting tables
and trying to get my business going.
We weren't doing great financially.
And now as we were dual
income, she's losing jobs,
so I'm like, man, I gotta step up.
And I actually gotta really
lead and begin to fight.
Reasons come before results,
and it was during this season
that I began to capture new reasons
like man, I gotta fight for my family.
Come on, I gotta hold tight to my faith.
I gotta really believe that we
can still have a good future,
and that we can get through this obstacle
if we keep going and we keep learning.
What I want you to do is write
down some reasons right now.
And the reason we're doing this,
I know you're here for
strategy and tactics,
we're gonna get those today.
I know you're here for the latest things,
we're gonna do those today,
but what I've learned is that
this is the stuff that
really matters friends.
That when we really are gonna
get through what's coming
in terms of the the uphill battle
of winning on social media,
the uphill battle of
standing out in your niche
and learning these new skills,
you gotta have strong reasons.
And as you're writing I
wanted, you just brainstorm,
write anything down, it
doesn't have to be super deep.
"You know what, I had
that dream vacation."
Where's that write it down?
"I've got that car that I want."
Write that down.
But then maybe what is it
that you're fighting for?
"Man, I'd love to be able
to support this cause.
"I would love to be able with
just with no problem at all
"to be able to just write a check
"to this organization that I care about.
"I want my son, my daughter
to have this kinda future.
"I want her to see mom
and dad doing this."
Or maybe dad left, you're a
single mom and you're like,
"I want my legacy to be this."
Let's capture some reasons.
And as you're writing, for
the rest of this session
I just wanna talk about 10 reasons
to go all in with online video right now.
These are some of the reasons that I have
that kept me motivated to
go through the struggle.
Because we're standing on stage right now,
and we're here at Grow With Video,
but I shot that first
video in 2010, y'all.
And I got started in video in 2003, right?
So there was a lotta
uphill fights to go through
to get where we are today, so
I had to have strong reasons.
Number one, these are just some reasons
that maybe you could pull
into your life as well.
But here are some from me:
become a creator, not just a consumer.
Creators are the ones that
win in the new economy.
There's plenty of consumers.
There's plenty of people
that want to watch content.
And I love, I'm a consumer
as well, love watching.
But when you step out and
start creating content,
it actually kinda does
something in your life,
you start contributing value to the world.
You start creating something
meaningful become a creator,
not just a consumer.
Second reason, you get
to create community.
I mean, this is insane
friends, like we're here,
like inner circle, but Dr. K's right here,
people know, David Goldsteins back here.
I wouldn't be standing on this stage
if it wasn't for him either.
It's crazy, all these,
that you're meeting people,
we're in a room, we're in
Vegas, the Sahara Hotel.
Community happens because you step out
and you start creating content.
It actually makes me think
of Nicole who's here.
Where's Nicole at?
Hey, Nicole.
And so it makes me think of Nicole.
She's a kids occupational therapist.
She punched fear in the
face, started posting videos,
and she's helping other
moms on her channel.
So she has something
like 40,000 subscribers,
but you can kinda see
her stats on the screen.
She's growing by 2,072
subscribers per month.
It's cool, right?
(audience cheering)
And that's 2,072 moms, right?
That are trying to figure out
how to get their newborn to latch.
That was awkward.
Okay, so you know.
(audience laughing)
Ha-ha, it's my favorite thing, okay.
And but she's helping people,
and community is forming.
She's meeting strangers and
now they're becoming friends.
And so creating community.
Number three is to
express your creativity.
Now, I want to attack a myth right now.
Some of where you are like, "That's mine.
"Yo, I'm an artist.
"Yeah, that's natural for me."
Some of you in this room
have believed the myth
that you're not creative.
That's not true.
All of us are creative.
I know that God has wove
greatness into all of our DNA
and you're creative in your own way.
See, sometimes we think creative is just,
creativity is just video, but
creativity is problem solving.
Creativity is figuring
out how to run a team.
out how to raise some kids
without them going crazy
and burning your house down.
Like expressing your creativity,
but when you start to share
content on the internet,
you get to put out creativity.
But I've learned that creativity
is unlocked by commitment.
Creativity is unlocked by commitment.
And so that's when we go all in,
when we go all in, then we start saying,
look, there's no turning back.
It's kinda like burning
the ships, burn the boats.
Because now it's like, we
better find a creative solution.
We're gonna do this video once a week.
Come hell or high water, I'm
uploading a video once a week,
no matter what.
And then you start getting creative
to figure out how it's done.
You start thinking, oh,
shoot, it's Tuesday,
the video's gotta come out.
Well, I guess I'm shooting all night long,
and I'm gonna be creative
with what caffeine beverage I choose.
You know what I mean?
You find a way, where there's
a will, where there's a way.
Commitment unlocks creativity.
Number four, I've learned that the reason,
I started to discover this,
when I started create content
make videos, stretch
myself put myself out there
that it has been the number one catalyst
of my personal growth.
That it's been stretching, challenging.
Post some videos get a
few negative comments
that are deeply personal
and accurate about you.
Makes you grow a little bit,
challenges you a little bit, right?
And so by stepping out in video,
my skills grew from just
doing it, my confidence grew,
my knowledge grew, problem
solving, resilience.
These things grow by just
stepping out and committing.
These are reasons, right?
Because we haven't even got
to like profit or anything.
You've got strong reasons,
if you just go, people go,
"Your channel is not growing that fast.
"Your podcast is not growing that fast."
You're like, "It's all good, man.
"I'm getting my muscles bigger right now.
"I'm not ready to compete
in the Iron Man yet.
"I'm just in the gym working it out.
"My reasons is the
personal growth I'm gaining
"from a commitment to this process."
Reason number five, build a portfolio.
So powerful once you
start sharing your voice,
your message, your answers,
your value on the internet,
LinkedIn, Instagram, you're
building a portfolio.
A portfolio of content
makes me think of Diana.
And Diana right now is
actually back on the cameras.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Yeah.
We were just, she actually recently joined
the Think Media Team doing
some, she's independent,
she helps us with some micro content
that you might see on my
Instagram and whatnot.
2016, had a full time job,
had a lot of responsibilities,
had all this kinda stuff, but
she committed and went all in.
She's uploaded 238 videos on her channel
over the last three years.
Now, now.
Her channel has this is amazing,
but it has 2,700 subscribers.
Not two million, not 200,000, 2,700.
Three years, 238 videos.
That's commitment man, that's hustle.
But, but in just the last two
months, in fact shout it out.
She just was able to quit
her jobs, have no bosses,
become completely her
own Entrepreneur Women,
running her own business.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Yeah.
Now she's trying to hire
people, she needs to hire people
to help her because of the
amount of clients she has.
How long you been full time Diana?
- [Diana] May 10th.
- May 10th, she knows the day.
The day she was able to say come on,
helping 10,000 entrepreneurs
become full time
doing what they love with online video.
It's possible, but I've been
so inspired by you Diana
because you've been all in.
And you've been all in when it's been hard
and when it hasn't been
super sexy or super flashy,
but she hasn't give up and she made it.
And she's been building
a portfolio of work
that is super inspiring.
I think about the portfolio that
we're building on Think Media.
I believe this, that every video I upload
is a contribution to my body of work.
It's part of my life's legacy.
And so as I'm uploading videos now,
and this was true back in
2010, 11, 12, that I was like,
okay, well, I'm thinking, people are like,
"This isn't very significant yet."
I'm like, well, yeah, just
give me 10 years, right?
It's all a contribution to
your legacy, your life's work.
A strong portfolio also leads
to unlimited future business.
When you've got a strong portfolio
on these social platforms,
that's what Diane is experiencing.
That's what we're
experiencing at Think Media.
You build a strong portfolio
and eventually, literally,
we have more business
than we could ever handle.
Like more people, like inquiries
Why?
'Cause we built a strong portfolio.
Not overnight, but over time.
Number six, get discovered.
We talked about it, people
are looking for answers.
As business owners,
as influencers that want to make profit
one of our big challenge is like,
"Yo, Sean, though, but what
if nobody knows me yet?"
Well, yeah, that's how
we all started y'all.
You know what I mean?
Nobody knew anybody
when they first started,
but you have to just start posting.
But what's so powerful is
that you can get discovered.
Write this down and think about this,
what is it you wanna be known for?
What is it you wanna be known for?
You have to be able to
answer that question,
and then you can start getting discovered
for that thing that
you wanna be known for.
"Well, Sean, I wanna be
known for these 15 things."
You probably are never gonna
get discovered for that
because if it's too broad,
but when you become,
when you know what you wanna
be known for, that'll be,
that'll help you reverse
engineer your content
and then you could get discovered.
We know that YouTube is the second largest
search engine in the world.
Arguably, there's, we
wouldn't be here at this event
if it wasn't for that single fact.
And once I discovered that,
and Video Ranking Academy
members understand this,
that people are going to YouTube
looking for answers to their questions.
And when nobody knows you,
they know their question,
they type it in and if
you show up in search
on the other side of that search result,
now somebody who doesn't
know you, knows you,
you get discovered.
And now you have a chance
for them to go deeper
with you in business,
maybe just watch more free content,
maybe join your email list,
maybe discover your products.
We've got people that are
in Video Ranking Academy,
real estate agents, people
discover their video,
and in the top three lines of text,
they've got their phone
number and their email
so they can just get on
the phone and sell houses
or do mortgages.
And so you can get discovered.
LinkedIn, I just pulled this up
because we've been active over there.
In the last 90 days 1,984
people have viewed my profile.
We're putting out strategic content.
A lot of people who had no idea who I was
are discovering me,
because I'm taking action
and posting content on
these strategic platforms.
Keep writing your reasons,
writing your reasons.
What are your reasons?
Building your reasons, the
fuel that's gonna fuel you
as you're building your brand online.
Number seven is personal branding.
There's maybe no greater accelerator
for building a personal brand,
than publishing content on line.
Personal branding is so important because
even if you just stay in,
you want to just accelerate in your career
more than ever before, people
that are seeking people
to join their companies,
they wanna hire people,
what do they do?
They go look at 'em online.
I'll tell you, of course,
we're a social media company,
but nobody would make it to Think Media
if we don't look at their Instagram page.
We don't look at that, we
look at their LinkedIn,
we look at the kinda content
that we're putting out there.
We're curious, what are they all about?
We're curious about, every
post you post on social media
is building your personal brand.
Like out of the overflow of the heart,
Facebook, Twitter and YouTube speaks.
If I go to your Facebook
page, and I just see like
26 outraged political
crazy comments or whatever,
I go, okay, this is who this person is.
Right?
We're building our legacy,
we're building our brand.
But when you are publishing,
so what do you want to be known for?
Reverse engineer back for that,
consistently publish content around that,
and then eventually, they're like,
"How did I become the YouTube guy?"
I started talking about
YouTube a lot for a long time.
And then it was like, "Dude,
you're like the YouTube guy."
Yeah, why?
Because you were talking
about it for a lot,
for a long time, so when
you're known for the one thing
you wanna be known for, talking about it,
it builds your personal brand.
And then like with a
strong personal brand,
companies wanna hire
you, you're in demand,
people wanna work with you.
Why are they gonna pick
one consultant, one coach,
one advisor over somebody else?
Personal brand, they look 'em up online,
They start stocking your Instagram page,
we gotta be thinking about these things.
I love this quote from Jay Z.
"I'm not a businessman,
I'm a business, man."
(audience cheers and applauds)
Right?
You gotta be thinking about that.
And and this might be a switch
that some of you in this room wanna make.
One of my mentors, Celine
Johnson told me that she said
"Sean, eventually you have to decide
"what are you using social media for?
"Are you using it for business
"or are you using it for personal?
"And if you're using it for business,
"then go all in in using it for business."
Like if you're using it for personal,
who even cares about any of this stuff?
Just just have like your few close friends
and your few family follow
you and be clear about that.
But if you're using it for business,
it's probably time to
go all in for business.
To stop trying to blend it, to
stop trying to worry about it
and to make every action
decision intentional
to create the end result that you want,
because you're a business, man.
All right, number, this is a good reason,
number eight, make money.
Make money, right?
And so when you, what are your reasons?
I mean, I for sure started back in 2010,
and kinda my journey was I was discovering
that there was the
power of ranking videos,
YouTube as a search engine.
And I discovered something
called affiliate marketing,
affiliate marketing.
And that's where you could sign up for
a site like amazon.com.
And if you recommend a product,
if I talked about a camera
and I put a link in the description below,
and someone clicked that link,
and they purchased something,
then I would get a commission on that.
And so if I was talking
about a camera or a lighting,
but on my personal channel,
I was doing videos,
I was like reviewing health products.
I was doing these gift ideas videos
during Christmas or whatever else.
And here's the deal, I really wanna make
a difference in the lives of people,
I wanna make an impact,
but I'm not trying to say
I'm just some saint here I'm
trying to make some money, man.
Is that fair.
- Yeah.
- Anybody else trying to make some money?
Come on, you need
provision for the vision.
You're not gonna be doing this very long
if you don't got any money coming in.
And so, one of my reasons was like,
yeah, I'm doing this, I wanna add value.
Of course, lead with value, of
course not be selly or weird,
but it's gotta be
connected to profit, right?
I think about Doctor Eye
Health, where's he at?
He's here.
Doctor Eye Health, right there, man.
Good to have you here.
This is crazy man.
Joseph, he's an Doctor of optometry
and he started posting videos
on his YouTube channel,
and it's just been going crazy.
In fact, these are his stats right here.
4,209 subscribers he's
growing per month right now.
Yeah, yeah.
(audience cheers and applauds)
He's in inner circle,
Video Ranking Academy.
And check it out four videos a month,
four videos a month, one a week.
Some of you are gonna do more,
but that's what we recommend.
When we're like, when we sum
this all up, if you're like,
"Sean, what's my strategy,
what's my game plan?"
If it's anything, it doesn't
need to be that crazy,
one thing a week, one video a week,
one video podcast a week,
we'll hit that more.
But he's been doing some cool stuff,
building his income a little
bit with affiliate marketing,
but he, I just asked him recently
how some things are going?
He's gonna be sitting on
a panel as the YouTube guy
in November at a
conference in San Francisco
called EyeInnovate, digital
marketing for eye doctors.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Cool, right?
So he's building his
personal brand, right?
And money's starting to come in,
and he's a creator not just a consumer,
he's doing all these things,
he's momentum starting to have for him.
He said this, what's really crazy
is the number one blog spot
for vision on the internet
reached out and they wanna
post some of his videos
on their post and they even wanna pay him
for letting them post his videos.
- Yeah!
- Yeah.
There is absolutely massive profit
by taking massive action
on this information.
Reason number nine, make
an impact, make an impact.
And when I think about doing online video,
man, you can make a major difference
a major impact in the world.
You can raise awareness for a cause,
raise money, change lives.
This is my good friend and co-author
of the book "YouTube
Secrets", Benji Travis.
And over like the last eight years or so
we've been partnering together,
I mean, it's him and his wife's event,
but my wife Sonja and I have
just participated every year
and tried to contribute whatever influence
and energy and money that we could.
And just this last
Dancemeber that they did,
they raised $325,000 for charity.
And I think over the last eight
years over $2 million raised
because they built influence
and so they can make a greater impact.
One of the companies we partner with
or nonprofits we partner
with at Think Media
is Compassion International.
And so as a team, we sponsor 20 kids.
Come on, just helping them get educated,
helping them get out of poverty.
And so this absolutely needs
to be connected to purpose
in our opinion, that's why we say,
we wanna help purpose
driven entrepreneurs.
And if you still got maybe a few reasons
what is one of your reasons?
What impact would you
wanna make in the world?
I've learned this, that eventually
and you might eventually
meet your own needs.
You're like, "Man, I hit a
financial level where like,
"we're somewhat comfortable,
we're somewhat settled."
I've even heard people say this,
"Yeah, we're making enough
money for me and my family.
"We're good here."
And to be honest friends,
some people, they actually think that
people trying to build wealth are selfish.
I actually think that if
you settle it's selfish,
because there's so much need
in the world, that it's like,
if you say, "Well, I
don't need more money."
Great, why don't you make more
and then give the rest away.
Because if you are able bodied,
if you've got the power to create wealth,
if you've got the power to take
action and do these things,
you can make a massive
difference and impact on people.
The final reason, reason number 10,
as we close this session,
reason number 10 is history and legacy,
history and legacy.
Let's think for a second about
the legacy you wanna build,
the next generation, the
next generation after that.
For me, these are some videos
on my personal channel.
And at the time, I was just hustling,
trying to figure out YouTube.
We were all over the place, man,
we had no idea what we were doing.
We were talking about the
Amazing Spider Man one day,
doing green bean recipes the next day,
going horseback riding, kind of vlog,
we had no idea what was going on.
But actually now when I look back,
I'm so grateful that I
uploaded all these videos.
Because someday our future children,
they're gonna be able to see this.
They're gonna be able to see
their father young and weird.
And I just think of it as
history, I think of it as legacy.
You're gonna be hearing from
Heather in just a moment.
And when we met just
a few short years ago,
she had not posted any videos at all.
She didn't have confidence
to get on video.
In fact, the reason that
we kind of met on Twitter,
she wanted to learn video,
but she punched fear in the
face; super uncomfortable.
And she just started posting videos.
And now she looks back
in just a few short years
at her channel, The Homeschool House.
Now it's at 13,000
subscribers, almost 14,000.
She's had over 500,000
people view her videos.
But I think one of the
most powerful things
is history and legacy.
That's her first video ever,
and there's young Kaylee,
her daughter in the video,
scared that she just got filmed, right?
Heather, and so, and this isn't
just three years from now,
this is 10 years from
now, 20 years from now,
looking back at the journey,
looking back at your journey,
this is why I want you
posting bad videos, right?
No, because one day you're
gonna be on this stage
or you're gonna be on your stage
or you're gonna be on whatever
stage that you wanna impact
and that you're gonna wanna be
able to play your first video
and be like, "Oh, man, that was weird."
But a lot of us hide fear, don't we?
Because we're like, oh, my
videos aren't that good yet,
hey, you want some bad
video so you can have
a powerful illustration
someday in the future.
And if anything, just to
remember and be able to
kinda laugh about it with your family.
And as I close with history and legacy,
it actually really reminds
me of my cousin Steven.
And my cousin Steven, passed
away a couple years ago.
In fact, the anniversary of
his death is in just two days.
And he passed away at 30 years old.
And man, I loved him so much.
In fact, he's one of the
greatest inspirations
in my life personally, entrepreneur,
just a guy that loved people, loved God.
In fact, one thing that
people would say about him
is every room he went in,
he left people better.
His mission was to leave people better
than when they first met him.
That no matter what encounter,
he just wanted to leave
the encounter better
than when you first met.
And man, Steven is
actually one of my reasons.
When he was living I felt like
we were always running
together, fighting together,
entrepreneurs together.
And now that he's passed
on I even think about him
and I imagine him from heaven looking down
and cheering me on and
being someone that is just
so meaningful and such a
motivating reason in my life.
And I think about this years ago,
he started a channel
called Remember When God,
and he shared a few videos on there.
I was just watching these over
the last couple weeks just,
moved and also thinking,
man, I'm so grateful though,
that he has shared.
This is some stuff, this video right here
is about our family about the Reeds.
And that's my mom's maiden name.
And one of the things about
the Reeds was that we,
we love to eat, we love food,
and she talks about that
and he is going through that,
so I get to remember Steve.
And I'm so thankful he
posted these videos.
On this channel just
a few videos he posted
he interviewed kind of his grandpa,
Grandpa Jesperson an interview with him.
This is the kinda thing that I think man
when it comes to video,
we have the power to
document moments, don't we?
We have the power to capture
moments with our family,
with our friends, with the people
that matter most to us in our life.
And so friends, I'm talking
about powerful reasons
that are gonna motivate
you when times get tough.
I hope you've been
writing down some reasons,
but I think that ultimately
the greatest reason
is connecting to the legacy
and the vision that you have
for your life and your family.
Maya Angelou said it this way,
"If you're gonna live, leave a legacy.
"Make a mark on the world
that can't be erased."
So friends now's the time to
go all in with online video.
Now's the time to punch fear in the face.
The stats are in, the facts are in,
and now's the time to
get strong enough reasons
that get you out of bed in the morning.
To say, shoot, it's not
going how I thought it was.
I'm not getting the views
that I thought I'd be getting,
but I'm gonna get up another day,
I'm gonna fight another day,
I'm gonna punch fear in the face again,
I'm gonna rise and grind again,
and I'm gonna keep fighting for my family,
my future, history, and legacy.
Thank you.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Thanks for checking out this episode.
We hope you got a ton of value.
And if you haven't already,
subscribe here to the Think Marketing Show
wherever you're watching or listening.
- And hey, it would mean the world to us
if you would rate and review
this show on Apple podcast.
- As we grow this movement of
purpose-driven content creators
we encourage you to
share it with a friend.
And we'll see you in the next episode.
(upbeat music)